[Musique]
et x et a fait partie des acteurs de
l'immobilier commercial présents ici sur
la zone paris ouest et c'est ici autour
de nous qu'il bâtit à sa manière le
renouveau de ce pôle commercial
vingt mille mètres carrés avec des
enseignes des espaces verts et diverses
activités livraison prévue en 2024 ont
rejoint tout de suite la responsable de
ce projet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous la responsable du projet et
ixia sur la zone paris ouest géraldine
yolain bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors où en est on dans le projet
d'aménagement de cette zone alors sur le
projet donc on est en phase de
finalisation de la première phase de
renouvellement urbain dont qui a
consisté véritablement rénover
complètement et donc en lecture
d'aménagement toute la zone donc dans
cette première étape donc avec vous
allez des ouvertures dans scène qui se
sont qu'ils sont ouverts depuis donc
septembre jusqu'à à peu près novembre
donc avec un étalement d'ouverture des
enseignes ce projet là donc dans cette
phase une a consisté véritablement à
retravailler tout la lisibilité urbaine
donc la façade commerciale de l' axe
principal avec une meilleure
accessibilité notamment une visibilité
au niveau des enseignes pour la partie
commerciale et c'est en deux phases
finalement il ya ces deux premiers
bâtiments mais il y en a un autre aussi
qu'il va apparaître exactement dans le
prolongement donc une deuxième phase va
intervenir notamment avec des on juge
les enjeux urbains de coeur d'îlot à
végétales notamment de déambulation
d'hyper mobilité donc une alternative à
la voiture donc sur cette deuxième étape
avec un vraiment un coeur d'îlot une
ambition parenthèse verte sur ce projet
là et là on est en plein dans le futur
des zones commerciales exactement
l'objectif qu'elle ne soit pas
strictement définies comme commercial
puisque l'objectif est véritablement
travailler dès mixité fonctionnelle donc
des fonctions autre que le commerce
complémentaire aux commerçants peut-être
par exemple ça peut être du service ça
peut être en effet dû de l'habitat ça
peut être véritablement du loisir
l'objectif est véritablement que les
fonctions se nourrissent les unes par
rapport aux autres pour en faire
vraiment une lecture des territoires est
une réponse aux besoins du territoire et
au-delà de proposer des nouvelles
activités qu'on n'avait pas encore dans
les zones commerciales c'est aussi une
offre de commerces qui varient qui
échangent exactement l'objectif est
aussi de créer une vraie singularité et
1 et des éléments différenciants donc 2
nos zones notamment des espaces
commerciaux donc ça passe aussi par un
mixité en tout cas de typologie de
formats et de profils de commerce avec
des porteurs de projets locaux qui vont
être complémentaire aux enseignes
nationales mais avec des tendances
lourdes diot la crise sanitaire qui
était déjà présente avant mais qui sont
impliqués avec section renforcer
l'objectif est aussi sur les ambitions
portées sur plus sur ce projet là c'est
vraiment travaillé notamment sur la
partie consommation valorisation de
toutes les richesses du territoire
consommation saine valorisation des
circuits courts donc on est vraiment sur
ces d'angelin de programmation
complémentaire aux enseignes nationales
on travaille on met en valeur toutes les
richesses du territoire et toutes les
richesses locaux locale par nom par
rapport aux bonds aux porteurs de
projets qui vont venir compléter les
enseignes nationales merci géraldine
yoland rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable du projet éthique c'est sur
les zones paris ouest et ixia promoteur
immobilier spécialisé dans les espaces
commerciaux et justement on va aller
voir le magasin des bd et son créateur
c'est un grand marché en vrac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous le créateur de day by day
maurepas grand marché vrac laurent sec
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors vous avez ouvert le 13 octobre
comment ça se passe les premiers jours
ici l'écouté le démarrage il est
incroyable
je suis j'attendais pas autant de monde
c'est évident donc on avait vraiment eu
un afflux de personnes mercredi jeudi
vendredi samedi bon j'avais fait un gros
tapage sur les réseaux les gens étaient
un peu curieux de mon histoire et voilà
il était en rendez vous donc on était en
très satisfait de ce démarrage alors
justement votre histoire parlons-en vous
étiez directeur commercial dans une
entreprise est aujourd'hui vous
retrouver à la tête d'un magasin après
particulier puisque vous faites du vrac
tous les produits sont vendus en vrac
comment ça s'est fait tout ça une prise
de conscience pour moi parce que j'étais
directeur commercial effectivement pas
entre 13 ans dans une entreprise qui
était un univers du snacking premium
donc super produit je représentais 40
marques différentes mais ont généré en
feront vendait des produits le stack
hills et les produits à emporter donc
ils sont emballés sur emballés et je le
disais mais c'est pas possible tous ces
déchets qu'on produit alors qu'on fait
des supers produits c'est frustrant donc
voilà j'ai eu envie de tourner la page
et puis d'aller vers un projet qui avait
plus de sens pour moi d'où cette idée
autour du vrac je connaissais débats et
des depuis très longtemps alors c'est un
magasin qui est particulier c'est quoi
la philosophie de ce magasin c'est rare
en plus dans la marque beats by dr
effectivement c'est le deuxième magasin
de ce format là il ya 75 des bd en
france mais ce sont des magasins de
centre-ville
épicerie droguerie hygiène les clients
ressortait des débats et des en disant
c'est génial mais on peut pas faire tout
nos courses puisqu'il ya pas les
produits frais donc on a été un peu plus
loin et le concept débats et des grands
marchés vrac y va c'est un débat et des
deux centres villes et qu'on installe en
périphérie et sur lequel on va rajouter
tous les produits frais avec des
commerçants engagé locaux qui m'ont
rejoint dans le projet pour défendre les
mêmes valeurs que celles que je voulais
porter avec des vagues alors justement
on est passé le fromage et le boucher le
maraîcher alors c'est qui qui sont
toutes ces personnes je suis suivre nos
super fier d'avoir réussi à convaincre
ces gens qui m'ont accompagné je vais
commencer par le boucher donc la
boucherie cardié c'était vraiment un
message à envoyer aux mort passe bien
aussi de dire que la proximité et la
périphérie pouvait être complémentaires
donc la boucherie cardié c'est une
boucherie du centre ville de maurepas et
qui a rejoint le projet en plus de son
activité ensuite on a derrière vous
ludovic biseau meilleur ouvrier de
france qui a une activité à rambouillet
et qui m'a fait l'honneur de me
rejoindre dans le projet et ensuite
alors pour ludovic un petit mot leleu
les les produits c'est le terroir donc
c'est vraiment la volonté de proposer
une gamme qui correspond à chaque
terroir
[Musique]
et l'oncle maraîchers alors et le
maraîcher ben on va avec cette offre de
produits fruits et légumes pouvoir aussi
surfer sur le souhait des gens d'avoir
aussi des produits locaux puisque là on
a une offre aujourd'hui un loft qui dans
le magasin elle est à plus de 60% d'une
provenance de moins de 80 kilomètres
d'ici donc on est sur les produits qui
viennent majoritairement des yvelines du
val d'oise de l'oise c'est de la culture
pleine terre c'est de la haute valeur
environnementale et notre maraîcher qui
fait les marchés de saint germain en
laye chat ou son leitmotiv c'est le goût
le goût le goût il dit les clients quand
ils achètent des fruits et légumes
les produits se conservent très très peu
et en plus ils ont plus de goût donc
voilà on a essayé et les retours qu'on a
depuis mercredi bas il ya déjà des gens
qui sont venus trois fois quatre fois en
cinq jours c'est étonnant et ils nous
disent vraiment les fruits et légumes
sont super bons donc voilà je suis
vraiment fier de les avoir tous
convaincu de me rejoindre et
bon après c'est le début c'est les
premiers jours mais c'est très
encourageant et puis on espère que les
gens seront satisfaits par cette offre
merci laurent sec merci aux mouches est
bon courage dans cette aventure il
coûtait du courage y en a et les gens me
donnent énormément d'énergie donc c'est
vraiment chouette et je rappelle donc
que vous êtes le créateur et dirigeant
du débat et démord pas grand marché vrac
[Musique]
et pour conclure sur le sujet du magasin
day by day à maurepas laurent sec a
lancé une campagne de financement
participatif objectif financer des
ateliers autour du potager que vous
voyez derrière moi et mais aussi des
ateliers autour des astuces anti
gaspillage rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran